I was flipping through the tabloids yeah
over the weekend and you know the
tabloids love to cover none other than
Justin Bieber
of course the Biebs the Biebs as only
you and I get the call and ride or a
good friend
and but we can't I come across this
picture of Bieber having fun in Mexico
uh-huh and I'm looking at the picture
and I think we can show it right there
there's Bieber having fun in Mexico I
guess he's handing out shots and there's
a lovely lady in a bikini next to him
and then I see the edge of the picture
widen out and I'm like I know that guy
that's Jeff Ross our producer
yeah turn to the side turn to the side
Jeff no be on the southern side other
side yeah
I'm still not seeing it take off your
jacket drop your shirt how are you doing
hanging out in Mexico with Bieber I ran
into Bieber yeah clearly you ran into
Bieber yeah but my question is you are
the producer you're behind-the-scenes
guy correct why is it that you're in the
tabloids and I'm never in the tabloids
I'm not hanging out with Bieber I'm not
doing anything cool he asked about you
what Bieber asked about you what like if
I was still alive I hate you said he was
very nice very nice guy very nice guy
yeah no I just I was more just steamed
that you know Here I am I'm supposed to
be the the face of this right right and
he Jeff Ross is out partying with Bieber
and he's in the Terriers again there he
is in the tabloids okay
the last time I was in the tabloids was
two years ago on TMZ do you remember
this story they ran this story right
here
TMZ really got me that I don't know how
they they just man but that story went a
crazy viral and trended
you